OK.
So that's our introduction
to the subject.
Now, we have to get going.
We have to explore how to set
up this scattering problem.
So equations that
we need to solve.
Well, what are the equations?
We will have a
Hamiltonian, which
is p squared over 2m
plus a potential v of r.
Need not be yet a
central potential.
As usual, we will think
of a wave function that
depends on r and t
that will be written
as a psi that depends on r times
e to the minus iet over h bar.
An energy eigenstate.
And then the equation
that you have to solve,
the time independent the
Schrodinger equation, becomes
minus h squared
over 2m Laplacian
plus v of r acting on psi
of r is equal to e psi of r.
So these are the equations
that you have seen already
endlessly in quantum mechanics.
These are equations we
write to get warmed up,
and we just repeat
for ourselves that we
have a Hamiltonian
in the picture where
the particles are scattering
off of a central potential.
Not a central
potential, in fact,
just often of a potential.
Work with energy
eigenstates, and these
are going to be the equation
for the energy eigenstates.
Now, let's write the first
picture of the scattering
process as some
sort of target here
or potential and
particles that come in
and scatter off
of this potential.
So we're looking for
energy eigenstates.
And we will try to identify
our energy eigenstates,
and what we're going to
assume is that this potential
is finite range as well.
Range.
Finite range we can
deal with potentials
that fall off relatively fast.
Already, the coolant potential
doesn't fall off that fast,
but potentials that fall faster
and the cooler potentials
are potentials that
are just localized,
which is pretty common
if you have an atom
and you scatter
things off of it.
If it's a neutral atom, the
potential due to the atom
is zero outside the atom, but as
soon as you go inside the atom
you start to experience all
the electrical forces that
are due to the nucleus
and the electrons.
So a finite range
potential, and we're
going to think of
solutions that--
OK, away from the finite
range our plane waves,
solutions of constant
energy specified
with perhaps some momentum,
so we will think of e as h
squared k squared over 2m.
This is a way of thinking of
the energy of a given energy
eigenstate.
So it's another
label for the energy.
This one, it looks like
I've done something
but I haven't done much except
to begin an intuition process
in your head in
which somehow these
are going to be related
to energy eigenstates that
have some momentum as they
propagate all over space.
So if I write that, I
could just simply put
this on the left hand
side and get an equation
that is kind of nicer.
Minus h squared
over 2m Laplacian
squared plus k squared plus
v of r psi of r equals zero.
OK, it's not really
a matter scattering
of solving this
equation at this moment.
There is infinitely many
solutions of this equation,
and most of them may
not be relevant for us.
We're not trying to find every
solution of this equation.
We're trying to
find solutions that
have something to
do with physics,
and you've done
that when you had
potentials in one dimension.
And that intuition is
going to prove invaluable.
So when you have a potential in
one dimension, you didn't say,
OK I'm going to find all
the energy eigenstates.
You said, let's
search for things
that are reasonable and
physically motivated,
so you put in a wave
that was moving in
and you said, OK, this
wave is a solution
until it reaches this point
where it just stops being
a solution and you need more.
If you put in this wave, you
will generate a reflected wave
and a transmitted wave.
Those two waves are
going to be generated,
and then you write an
ansatz for this wave,
some coefficient a e to the
ikx, b e to the minus ikx, c
e to the other, and then
you solve your equation.
So we need to do the same thing
with this kind of equation
and this kind of potential.
We have to set up
some sort of situation
where we have the physics
intuition of a wave that
is coming in and then whatever
the system will do to that wave
to upgrade it into
a full solution.
So that's what we want to do
here in analogy to that thing.
This could be called
the incoming wave,
and this whole thing the
reflected and the transmitted
could be called the scattered
wave, the thing that
gets produced by the
scattering process.
So if you had that there is lots
of solutions of that equation,
if v was identical to zero,
if you had no potential,
you could have
lots of solutions,
because in fact if the
potential is not zero,
plane waves are always
solutions without any potential.
Particles that move as
plane waves so if equal
zero, plane waves of the
form psi equal e to the ikx
are solutions with k equal
the square root of k dot k.
Or with k squared
equals k dot k.
Plane waves are always
solutions of this equation.
So if plane waves are solutions
of this equation for v
equal to zero, this
is the same thing
as saying here
that ae to the ikx
is a solution of this
equation as long as you
don't hit the potential.
So here, we're going to do
something quite similar.
We're going to say that we're
going to put in an incident
wave function, and I will
instead of writing psi,
I will call it 5x.
The incident wave function 5x is
going to be just e to the ikz.
So it's a wave function.
I call it phi to
distinguish it from psi.
Psi in general is
a full solution
of the Schrodinger equation.
That's our understanding of psi.
So phi, it reminds you that
well, it's some wave function.
I'm not sure it's a solution.
In fact, it probably is
not the solution as soon
as you have the potential
different from zero.
So is this common, we
forget that ksv equals zero,
and now we put an incident wave
function which is of this form.
This solves the equation
as long as you're away
from the potential.
This is true, it's a solution
of the Schrodinger equation
away from v of r.
Away from v of r means
wherever v of r is equal zero,
you have a solution.
Nevertheless, so if we call
the range of the potential--
let's call the range of the
potential finite range a--
that is to take that if
there is an origin here
up to a radius a, there is some
potential and beyond the radius
a the potential vanishes.
So this definitely works.
It's all ks away from vr or
as long as r is greater than a
for whatever value
of z you take.
This is fine, so
here is our wave,
and now this is just
the incident wave.
This is not going to
be the whole solution.
Just like in the one dimensional
case, there must be more.
So what is there more?
And our challenge to
begin with this problem
is to set up what
else could there be.
So looking at it,
you'd say, all right.
So the thing comes in.
If there is
scattering, particles
are sometimes going to go
off in various directions.
So the outgoing wave, here
there were outgoing waves
reflected and transmitted.
The outgoing wave in the three
dimensional scattering problem
should be some sort of spherical
wave moving away from r
equals zero, which
is the origin.
That should be the other
wave that I would write.
So my ansatz should
be that there
is some sort of spherical
wave that is moving away.
So to complete this with
a spherical outgoing wave.
So while here this is
a plane wave moving
in the direction
of the vector k,
if I want to write the spherical
wave, I would write e to the i
just kr.
E to the ikr is
spherically symmetric,
and it propagates radiantly out.
If you remember
as usual that you
have e to the minus iet over h
bar, so you have kr minus et,
that is a wave that
propagates radially out.
So maybe this is kind
of the scattered wave.
This e to the ikr
moving out everywhere
would be your scattered wave.
If that is the
scattered wave, remember
the scattered wave should
solve the Schrodinger equation.
In fact, the sum
of these two should
solve the scattering equation.
On the other hand,
we've seen that this
solves it as long as you're
away from the potential,
and therefore this
should also solve it
if you're away
from the potential.
So I ask you, do you think this
solves the Schrodinger equation
when you're away
from the potential?
Would e to the ikr
solve the equation?
Well for that, you would
need that if you're away
from the potential, do
you have Laplacian of e
to the ikr roughly equals zero?
Is that true?
Would it solve it.
No.
It doesn't solve it.
Doesn't even come
close to solving it.
It's pretty bad, but the reason
it's bad is physically clear.
This wave as it expands out
must become weaker and weaker
so that the probability
flux remains constant.
You know, you don't
want an accumulation
of probability between a shell
at one kilometer and a shell
at two kilometers.
So whatever flux is going out
from the shell in one kilometer
should be going out
of the bigger shell.
So therefore, it
should fall off with r.
Oh, I'm sorry.
I didn't write this well.
So if you are going
to have this to be
a solution of the Schrodinger
equation outside of vr
equals zero, you should
have Laplacian k squared
of this thing equal to zero.
So if this is equal to zero and
the potential is equal to zero,
the whole thing
is equal to zero.
So we need this to hold.
But even this one, of
course, is not true.
It is just absolutely not true.
The one that works
is the following.
Laplacian plus k squared
of e to the ikr over r
is equal to zero for
r different from zero.
This is a computation
I think you guys have
done before when
you were studying
the Hermiticity of p squared.
You ended up doing
this kind of things.
This Laplacian produces a delta
function at r equals zero,
but r equals zero is not the
place we're interested in.
We're trying to find
how the waves look away
from the scattering center.
So we need this to
hold away from r
equals zero, in fact,
bigger for r bigger than a.
One way of checking
this kind of thing
is to remember that the
Laplacian of a function of r
is in fact one over r d
second dr squared r times f.
That's a neat formula for the
Laplacian of a function that
just depends on r.
If it depends on theta and
phi, it's more complicated.
But with this function, it
becomes a one line calculation
to do this, and the r
here is just fantastic,
because by the time you
multiply by r this function is
just exponential.
You take two derivatives,
you get minus k squared,
and then the r gets
canceled as well
and everything works
beautifully here.
And so this equation holds OK.
And then we do have a
possible scattered wave.
So we're almost there.
We can write the scattering
wave size scattering
of x could be e to the ikr over
r and then leave it at that.
But this would not
be general enough.
There is no reason why
this wave would not
depend also on theta and phi.
Here is the z
direction, and there's
points with angle theta, and if
you rotate it with some angle
phi here, and therefore
this function could as well
depend on theta and phi.
So we'll include that
factor f of theta and phi.
Now you would say,
look, you have
a nice solution of the
Schrodinger equation
already here, and what
should you be doing?
Why do you add this factor?
With this factor, it may
not be anymore a solution
of the Schrodinger equation.
The Schrodinger equation is
going to have a Laplacian
and it's going to
be more complicated.
Well, this is true and we
will see that better soon,
but this will remain
an approximate solution
for r much bigger than a is the
leading term of the solution,
leaving term of the solution.
So if you have a leading
term of a solution here,
this is all you want.
You are working at r much bigger
than a, and your whole wave
and finally be written.
So your full wave psi, or your
full energy eigenstates psi
of rt, is going to be
equal, approximately
equal to e to the ik--
well, I'll write it this way.
Phi of r, that incident
wave we wrote--
I wrote if x there, I'm sorry.
Plus psi scattering of--
I should decide x or r.
Let's call this r.
And I should call this r.
Psi of r plus psi
scattering of r,
and it's therefore equal to e
to the ikz plus f of theta phi e
to the ikr over r, and this is
only valid for r much bigger
than a.
Far away.
This had an analog in our
problem in one dimension.
In one dimension, you set up a
wave and you put here the wave
and there is a reflected wave,
and there's a transmitted wave,
and in setting the problem, say
this is valid far to the left,
far to the left meaning at least
to the left of the barrier,
this is valid to the right.
And these were exact
solutions in this region here.
You can't do that well, but
you can do reasonably well,
you can write solutions that
are leading term accurate
as long as you are far away.
So this is the first step in
this whole process in which we
are setting up the
wave functions that
is the most important equation.
This is the way we're going
to try to find solutions.
Now, when you try
to find solutions
at the end of the
day, you will have
to work in the region
r going to zero.
So sooner or later
we'll get there.
But for the time being, we
have all the information
about what's going on far
away, and from there we
can get most of what we need.
In particular, this
f of theta and phi
is the quantity we
need to figure out.
This f of theta
and phi is called
the scattering amplitude.
F of theta and phi called
scattering amplitude.